[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi
27 juin l'association manu coise
éducatives et culturelles fête ses 10
ans ils vous donnent rendez vous pour un
spectacle rétrospective
retour sur cette décennie l'association
78 tours organise son 4e festival
international de magie professionnels de
l'illusion internationaux seront
présents
magic flash et cristaux view faisant
chanter en plateau un autre spectacle
sur la musique de michael jackson et
avec des chorégraphies originales
l'association angie dans solidarité vous
propose une soirée avec le roi de la pop
une association de danse qui fête ses 10
ans avec un spectacle or ils iront aux
et audrey chaillou ont assisté aux
répétitions de la mecque avant cette
représentation spéciale j'ai été voir un
spectacle de shia c'était le spectacle
avatar ya cinq ans et ben ça m'avait
beaucoup plu et j'ai voulu essayer de
faire de la danse avec elle et je suis
resté depuis la prof de danse allait
super c'est la meilleure une professeure
de danse apprécié dans une association
qui fête ses dix ans l'association manic
oise éducatives et culturelles prépare
un spectacle rétrospective de cette
décision
des nouveautés aussi ce qu'ont fait pas
que des anciens morceaux mais on a
sélectionné
les meilleurs enfin pour nous dans ce
qu'on a fait jusque là en 2009 ils
étaient trois lancers cette association
elle compte aujourd'hui une cinquantaine
de danseurs de tous les âges
l'association fait essentiellement c'est
des spectacles de danse que l'on fait
des activités aussi culturelles ont fait
les capitales européennes
mais cette année on est parti à berlin
il ya deux trois ans on était parti à
londres avec est un projet qui a été
monté de toutes pièces par les ados le
spectacle c'est ce samedi 29 juin à 17
heures et à 20 heures 30
la couturière s'adapte au style de la
chorégraphe la street dance
s'il demande à chaque fois de voir les
chorégraphies cas-là proposé pour
pouvoir créer les costumes ils s'étaient
donné rendez vous dans dix ans et les
voici sur scène pour fêter cela
ils vous attendent pour ce show
anniversaire à la maison de
l'environnement
[Musique]
un vent de magie va souffler sur ce
plateau nous ont rejoints cristaux et
magic flash de l'association 78 tours et
vont nous parler d'un spectacle de magie
internationale qui aura lieu ce week-end
à vincent le bretonneux met tout de
suite dans se mettre dans l'ambiance va
faire un petit tour de magie mais aussi
pierre quel stagiaire à la rédaction qui
va nous assister enfin expliquez nous
alors tout d'abord faire un petit test
de connexion ensemble marylène honneur
aux femmes
quel paquet choisissez-vous le rouge le
bleu écoutez ça tombe bien ils sont bien
placés donc hier vous aurez le paquet
bleus je veux demander maintenant de
prendre chacun un paquet alors on va
saisir des mystères vraiment ne montrez
pas les cartes voilà prenez les cartes
et vous aller distribuer des cartes une
à une à les distribuer les cartes une à
une
allez jean alesi allez-y dont je pense
qu'ils vont nous le fait sentir une
petite voix intérieure qui va vous
inviter à vous arrêter à un certain
moment on n'est pas obligé de vous
arrêter au même moment par exemple il
aime vous pouvez vous arrêter quand vous
voulez et pierre également quand vous le
voulez avant qu'on arrive à la fin vous
arrêtez s'il vous plaît marylène
attention continue à tant d'égards du
jeu en main super mouche policiers
quelle carte 7,4 pierre où cette carte
vous aviez m celle-ci celle ci ok alors
on va la prendre et on va la mettre ici
sur le jeu de marine et marylène pardon
voulait prendre quelques car je vous ai
pas demandé voulait choisir celle ci ou
celle ci pour écouter ça tombe bien ça
ne change rien allez y mettez la carte
sur le jeu de pierre vous remettre le
jeu par dessus qui errent sur le vôtre
marylène sur le vôtre c'est exactement
on va réaliser tout ça super et là
attention petit tour de passe passe
hop là regardez pierre rappela le carter
reviens vers vous et marylène lagarde
revient vers vous non c'est pas terrible
comme tour mais on va essayer de faire
un petit peu mieux vous avez choisi une
carte vraiment au hasard on est d'accord
complètement au hasard le jeu bleu
c'était le vôtre la carte rouge le jour
où c'était le vôtre la carte bleue vous
la voyez où ça allait la super regarder
alors moi je veux même pas y toucher
prenez là sans la montrer prenez-la
faites la glisser sous le tapis sans la
montrer super à les imaginer une régate
sortait la carte rouge impeccable
parfait alors là ce qui serait un
miracle ça serait vous soyez arrêté sur
les deux mêmes cartes
ça serait vraiment un miracle écoutez ce
que voulait retourner s'il vous plaît
les cartes que vous avez des
sélectionnés tous les deux le set de
coop et le ca d'autres oeuvres alors là
c'est vraiment un mirage
par un miracle c'est aussi toutes les
cartes sont des sets de très peu bah en
fait alors je vous cache pas que toutes
les cartes sont les mêmes mais je ne
sont pas du tout des sets de traitement
ce sont des cartes qui sont complètement
blanche complètement blanche on peut
dire c'est que cette idée on peut
regarder elles sont complètement blanche
voilà comme quoi finalement les choix ne
sont pas toujours ceux que l'on croit
merci merci de collaboration pierre
merci beaucoup mari d'anne nous gêner
ses devoirs à faire en attendant on va
parler avec vous cristaux donc ce
week-end on va pouvoir voir de la magie
dans tous les magasins le bretonneux
dans différentes salles plusieurs shows
racontez moi
le 4e festival que qu'on fait
l'association des 78 tours
on a fait en 2013 2014 2015 et là ça
fait quatre ans qu'on n'avait pas fait
donc là on a mis la gomme c'était
vraiment et là il ya des artistes
exposent exceptionnelle pendant tout le
week-end
c'est non-stop justement c'est cette
dimension internationale parce qu'ils
viennent de partout certes exactement on
ad'ailleurs d'imiter qu'il revient tout
droit de las vegas où il était
american's got talent' et après on va
diverses autres artistes qui tournent
vraiment dans le monde comme charlie par
exemple ont également nestor hato
également qu'ils tournent enfin qui fait
tout on n'est pas sur un niveau france
mais comment sur un niveau international
4e édition j'imagine ça va être
compliqué à organiser pour faire venir
votons oui c'est pour ça qu'on ne fait
pas tous les ans mais c'est beaucoup de
boulot
donc c'est pour ça que là mais là on a
mis le paquet c'est la première fois
qu'on fait venir autant d'artistes
internationaux
donc ça c'est le gala du samedi soir
mais il ya aussi des numéros des galas
gradé des numéros toute la journée faire
un pas très dure 11 heures samedi et
dimanche à partir de 14 heures
auxquelles elle joue ce soir un grand
show en gros pour vous dire on a trois
spectacles le samedi
ensuite on a un gala des 78 tours donc
les artistes de l'association qui vont
faire leur propre gala est donc le grand
gala international ensuite à 20h30 et le
dimanche ça continue comme ça parce
qu'on a également encore trois
spectacles oui tout à fait c'est
vraiment il faut venir il faut réserver
rapidement parce que ça se remplit ça se
remplit très vite il ya déjà des
spectacles qui sont pratiquement les 78
points comme vous réserve et là dessus
je conseille de réserver
vraiment maintenant le samedi matin
c'est là où il fera encore un peu frais
dont on peut encore réserver pour le
spectacle de 11 heures et les autres
spectacles je tiens à dire que pour le
spectacle de 11 heures
j'ai l'impression que les gens ne sont
pas matinaux et pourtant alors vous
allez profiter un petit peu de la
fraîcheur de la nuit comme qui a
rafraîchi la salle de la tour et ce
spectacle donc magique duo duel
moi je laissais mon coup de coeur ses
nouvelles créations
enfin voila c'est vraiment un spectacle
interactif où c'est carrément le public
qui va choisir le déroulement du
spectacle donc vraiment non c'est une
vraie à 20h activités et j'arrive
vraiment à ceux qui veulent venir le
matin c'était la peur à avoir vraiment
un beau spectacle vraiment novateur va
devenir le samedi matin aux heures voir
ce ce magnifique duo magic bio duel qui
s'appelle magic du raid a eu lieu c'est
un ballon qui finit en duel comme ça
arrive parfois mais après la faillite le
cas demain 14h qui excédent qui
excellent s'attaque là que pour enfants
léon belly j d'europa casino pourrait
retrouver toute la programmation site
internet qu'on assistait tout à leur
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur d'autres
plates bandes ou plutôt le matin à
l'hormadi 11h sensi tôt le matin jusqu'à
tard le soir
le dimanche un peu moins tu as mais
effectivement ça commence à 11h et ça se
termine 9e galette à 20h30 donc c'est à
l'espace de kobe alors attention ceux
qui ne le savent pas il ya la salle de
la tour et le grand gala
anthony doob de personnes qu'on attend
se fera au gymnase directement de lieu
de rendez vous on fait attention
merci beaucoup merci merci une autre
forme de magie celle du patrimoine la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet fait
son festival
au programme de la restauration locale
avec même un méchoui le dimanche et de
nombreuses animations feu d'artifice
samedi soir et bal folk le lendemain que
vous choisissiez les troupes de lax les
libérateurs américains vous serez les
bienvenus à la reconstitution historique
organisée par l'association 79e memory
groupe c samedi et dimanche aux
clayes-sous-bois vous pourrez même
assisté à la scène de reconstruction de
reconstitution de la libération de la
commune une clôture de festival c'est
votre rendez vous dans les salles de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa de
saint-cyr-l'ecole ce week-end ce sera la
clôture de la 9ème édition du festival
les yeux pleins d'étoilés on vous attend
nombreux évidemment avec plein de films
et de nombreuses surprises et surtout un
film qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur cyrano de bergerac qu'on vous
présentera le vendredi 28 juin à 20h30
séance unique accompagné par mois je
vous ferais je me ferai un plaisir de
vous expliquer pourquoi c'est un grand
film
alors évidemment gérard depardieu son
prix d'interprétation à cannes en 90
ce grand texte de mon restant une
histoire vraiment formidable nouvelle
histoire d'amour
un grand moment à vivre en famille à
partir de 10 ans ça sera des souvenirs
pour toute la vie et nous continuerons
dimanche 30 juin à 10 heures avec une
séance très spéciale d'un ciné conte
dans le ciel c'est une création
originale des yeux d'elsa en partenariat
avec versailles grand parc
c'est une séance gratuite alors le
principe est simple c'est un spectacle
hybride entre film il y aura la
projection de quatre films et spectacles
vivants puisque une conteuse charles
gillot interviendra entre les films et
fera de ce spectacle un moment magique
puisque elle lira en fait les histoires
et on va vivre avec elle les aventures
de stella l'étoile qu'elle incarne dans
sa quête initiatique ce sera donc le
dimanche 30 juin à 10 heures au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa à partir de 3 ans et
c'est une séance gratuite
[Musique]
une nuit pour honorer le king of pop et
récolter des fonds pour une association
mj tu danses solidarité association
créée suite au décès du chanteur pour
lui rendre hommage
vous donne rendez vous au théâtre de
villepreux pour un spectacle de chants
et de danses avec des professionnels
parmi eux enzo radicaux le plaisir wa
vainqueurs catégorie en fin de
l'émission à la recherche du nouveau
michael jackson en 2010 ill will be
there de nouveau tous les bénéfices sont
reversés à l'association leucémie espoir
le tarif donc c'est 12 euros adulte et
moins de 15 ans du héros donc vraiment
très abordable voilà donc qu'on souhaite
en fait toucher le plus de monde
possible et passer un bon moment tout en
étant généreux je pense que c'est
possible
une compétition musclée au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
tournoi de crossfit cette unique épreuve
de qualification pour la france pour les
championnats du monde se déroule du 28
au 30 juin
3500 spectateurs sont attendus chaque
jour les templiers d'elancourt
organisent leur traditionnelle fête de
fin de saison ce samedi 29 juin barbecue
remise de trophées et tournoi de flag
licenciés ou non pouvait venir passer la
journée au sein du club de football
américain
direction paris pour une balade
animalière
[Musique]
et en ces temps de canicule pourquoi ne
pas décaler sa balade au zoo au soir
tous les jeudis jusqu'au 15 août le parc
zoologique de paris propose des
nocturnes reportages des pôles piloquet
de nos confrères dia grand paris pas de
repos pour les stars du zoo de paris les
visites nocturnes initié en 2016 sont de
retour tous les jeudis jusqu'au 15 août
l'occasion de profiter d'une ambiance
différente dans le parc bordé par le
soleil couchant de 19h à 1h du matin le
zoo laissera donc ses portes ouvertes
pour permettre aux visiteurs d'observer
les comportements un peu différent des
animaux le parcours de visite est ouvert
jusqu'à 22 heures permettant d'observer
les comportements des animaux avant la
tombée de la nuit et les comportements
des animaux sont bien souvent différent
beaucoup d'animaux notamment quand il
fait chaud comme c'est le cas l'été sont
moins visibles dans la journée ils se
ils se cachent ils se mettent à l'abri
du soleil et le soir avant le coucher du
soleil ils sortent et sont du coup
davantage visibles et s'offre ainsi au
au regard des visiteurs et donc c'est
essentiellement cette expérience unique
de visites qui proposait entre des
rhinocéros chamailleurs des otaries en
plein repos mérité ou des tapirs à
l'heure du repas collectif les nocturnes
permettent donc de découvrir les
coulisses des petites habitudes de fin
de journée des animaux divisé en deux
temps la soirée animalière du zoo de
paris est partagé entre l'observation et
la détente un afterwork originale qui
commence par des rendez vous pédagogique
sur certaines espèces du parc nous
aurons systématiquement avant 22h des
présentations d'animaux notamment des
nourrissage qui met en avant certaines
de nos espèces phares tels les otaries
les girafes ou les babouins de guinée
une fois le parcours de visite fermer à
22h on peut boire un verre se restaurer
et danser presque jusqu'au bout de la
nuit
l'objectif est de présenter un une autre
expérience de visite au parc zoologique
de paris et un afterwork unique sur
paris et la possibilité de combiner un
moment à la fois pédagogique convivial
et festif
le tout dans un cadre exceptionnel vous
avez jusqu'au 15 août pour profiter
d'une balade crépusculaire dans les
allées du parc zoologique de paris
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 choisir merci
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
idées sorties
[Musique]
oh
ouais